[Arabic recitation]
in the chapters regarding the etiquates
and rulings
with respect to relieving oneself.
Will you go anywhere?
The author says
and it is furthermore furthermore.
Yesterday of course we discussed
relieving oneself in a person in the
people's path. relieving oneself where
people sit, a place where people can
be harmed by person's waste.
Here the author tells us it is likewise
disouraged
that a person relieve himself urinate in
the place where he is bathing the
place where he is taking a bath to
relieve oneself there. Now in order to
understand this chapter properly, we
have to
properly visualize
the way that
the companions
were bathing
in order to understand exactly what the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
prohibiting.
Because when he tells them, "Do not
urinate
where you bathe,"
he's speaking to
them regarding
where they usually bathe. And his ruling
is based on the way that they bathe.
So, how would they bathe?
They didn't have bath houses
many of the western or even
northern
lands or even eastern lands did bath
houses and outouses these things were
very rare in the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's region in the Arab
peninsula
rather they would relieve themselves in
if they were in Medina or in Mecca, they
would relieve themselves in known areas
that were far away enough where they
could have some privacy and also the
waste would not accumulate and harm the
people in the village or the city.
And second of all, when they would
bathe, they would usually bathe in their
homes or
in an area set aside beside their homes
where they could have some privacy.
Now, were there drains and plumbing and
all of these things? No, of course not.
Right? It would just be ground. And this
is why we find that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he would
bathe
the way that he would bathe is he would
wash his hands three times. Aisha
describes it. He would wash his hands
three times and then his front and back
private parts and then he would make woo
except for his feet.
Then he would wash his head three times
and then he would wash the right side of
his body. followed by the left side of
his body. Then he would move places
and then wash his feet at the end.
Why would he move places? Well, it
wasn't a drain and a a shower or a place
a a basin. It was just outside
in the sand, in the dirt. And so he
would move places from the place where
all the, you know, dirt came off of his
body at and move to a clean place in
order to wash his feet so as to leave
whatever he washed off of his body where
it is and not track it with his feet.
And so this is why he would wash his
feet last.
Likewise, we see that the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam would tell the
companions and teach them to move places
when they go to wash their feet
when they are bathing. Why is this?
Because they don't have drains. It's
just the grout, right?
And so when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam prohibits the companions
from urinating where they are bathing,
this is where they are bathing. This is
important for us to visualize because
the ruling, the command or the
prohibition that comes from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a
prohibition
based on
their common their common
practice,
right?
So here
this is
he's one of the generation that came
after the companions. They're the
ones that learned from the companions.
They were the companions of the
companions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. He says, "I met a man
who was a companion of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam for as long
as Abua was his companion."
Who is this companion that he's talking
about?
No. and has had a lot more time with
with the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
than Abu. Do you guys remember when Abu
accepted Islam?
Huh?
No. in Hibba. Hiba remember he was given
of the of the war booty of Kiba. So
he was either there at the very tail end
or he came right after. So that makes
his companionship of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam for about 4
years 9 months there thereabouts. Okay.
And so who is this companion? Well,
the point here is that we don't know who
it is based on the information that the
author gives us. Could be any number of
companions. However, does it matter? Do
we need to know who the companion was in
order to accept the narration?
Huh?
It wouldn't matter because Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala he
has
thank you he has accepted
the he has judged all of the companions
to be trustworthy in the Quran.
Right? So it doesn't matter who the
companion was. All we need to know is
that he was a companion.
And
he says that this companion of the
prophet Sam.
[Silence]
So this companion says the messenger of
Allah
discouraged us prohibited us from
from
brushing or combing our hair daily or
urinating in the place where we bathe.
So a couple things to unpack here. What
does this mean? He prohibited
that a person comb or brush his hair
daily.
Again,
did they have short hair my hair
here or or your hair or your hair? No.
Most of them their hair was long and it
was never left loose. The Arab men never
left their hair loose. They would braid
their hair and they would always cover
it. Always. They would always have
usually a turban over it. And so when a
person would brush his hair, this means
that he is taking out his braids,
brushing the hair, rebraiding it every
single day. this becomes
an entire ordeal, right?
And so the prophets of the law as
prohibited that a person brush his hair
daily
and this is for men only. This is not
for women. Women will brush their hair
daily. As a matter of fact, they are
encouraged to do their hair hair daily
in order to remain attractive and
captivating for their husbands. But for
men,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam would
prohibit them from brushing their hair
and doing their hair daily for a very
important reason. Who could tell us what
that reason is?
Not to waste time.
Well, then why would women be doing it?
Be wasting time. Huh?
To be unlike women. Well, very close.
Yes. to be unlike women in the sense
that they are not
you know soft and and you know
constantly doing their hair and staring
at theirelves in the mirror every day
for an hour or two on end and so forth.
Men are not supposed to be this.
This is why in the books of
famously said
that the comb should be carried in
travel not by a resident. The comb
should not be carried by the resident.
Meaning always have your comb, always
combing your hair, always doing yourself
up. But for the traveler, he would have
a comb with him. Right? And the reason
for this is so that the man focus on
other things and that there be a level
of natural hardness that the men exhibit
that differentiates them from women.
And he prohibited that they urinate in
their place of bathing.
And this is
definitely for the one who is bathing
where there is no drain for the water to
go away. But if a person were bathing in
a stream or bathing in a river or
bathing in a place where water is
running, then this narration would not
apply. In the correct opinion of the
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.